hello welcome to hollywood we're here at
the world famous universal studios
behind five of the films in the running
for oscars this weekend let's take you
through some of the nominees in a year
where escapism through film has felt
much needed
i always wanted someday to make a
musical i always knew in the back of my
mind it would be west side story people
were craving joy
the introspection and the
feeling unsettled that we we've all
shared really drove me back to that time
i'm venus i'm serena i was excited about
shocking and surprising people so what'd
you think something wicked
i just loved being here so much have you
never done pictures without those
eyelashes no nope and i never will
i just completely fell under its spell
sorry
i got along for a second
people have been curious about the royal
family forever
you letting yourself be led by fear or
by love
fear a hundred percent fear
the past isn't it
many of this year's films have powerful
political themes from conflict in
northern ireland to climate change to
racial division as quite often with the
oscars politics eclipses show business
the sunshine state the hollywood glamour
the movie is designed to whisk us away
from reality it's a very long way from
the conflict in ukraine but the war will
no doubt feature at this weekend's
oscars
this is the 94th academy awards and over
the years among the tears triumphs and
total disasters it's long been a
platform for political sentiment so this
year ukraine is likely to colour the
narrative it would be interesting how
they rise to that challenge and they
should in some way i think that's
important i think when you're given that
platform and you know there's so many
eyes of the world watching it then then
that's the right place to be
to be um talking about it i'll be
curious to see how much it pops up um
but i have a feeling there's gonna be a
lot of love and support for the people
of ukraine
certainly there's going to be a lot of
urgency about the climate uh and then i
think mostly people are just going to
celebrate film and story
could this include an appearance by
president vladimir zelensky given his
background in acting ceremony producer
will packer hasn't ruled it out the
show's still in process um and we're
going to be very thoughtful about how we
acknowledge where we are in the world
but the show's still in process so
that's not something that we would
definitively say one way or another at
this point
at the academy museum it's apparent some
of the most impactful moments in oscar's
history have been those speeches
reflecting the politics of their time
marlon brando won best actor for his
part in the godfather and he chose to
respectfully decline that award and
sense the teen little feather the
treatment of american indians today
by the film industry
excuse me she was cheered and booed
i think people
know that it's a very
well-watched platform where they can
talk about issues which are important to
them climate change is real it is
happening right now
crucially the oscars offers a stage like
no other to have wage equality once and
for all and equal rights for women in
such tumultuous times impossible to
separate the politics from the party
well i'm joined now by la film critics
amy nicholson and brooke obie
we're expecting ukraine to feature
aren't we i was brought up at the sags
the critic choice awards the baftas it's
something that you can't really avoid
this big world event
yeah and and with good reason i'm so
glad i've been to kiev it's one of my
favorite cities on earth and i really am
glad that the world is at least rallying
behind the people of ukraine i mean the
producer will packer he said it is meant
to be a moment of escapism this weekend
but um i mean you can't really avoid
talking about this big political event
it's always going to be on the hearts
and minds of the people that are are
watching but definitely on the
presenters and you know the people who
are going to be accepting their awards
will definitely hear quite a bit about
ukraine i believe and of course the
other big challenge for the academy to
deal with is the fact that the audience
numbers were just so low last year the
worst audience figures ever and they're
trying to change that this year by
bringing back the host we've got wanda
sykes amy schumer regina hall i managed
to catch up with regina and here's what
she had to say to me
it's crazy that you know i'm one of them
but it's exciting it's very exciting and
of course my my my co-hosts are
wonderful and i love them so much we
just get together get high and just go
let's just see where it's going to fall
no we have a great cast of writers and
um they sit and and and we come and
bounce ideas off each other i think
that's what's so great it's so
collaborative
how do we feel about the host coming
back then this is historic i mean this
is the first time that three women will
be hosting the oscars so i think that's
really exciting i think people want to
see
different people hosting they've teased
us a bit with a few sort of trailers
we've got to see the chemistry of them
they seem to to gel quite well don't
they they do although i'll say i'll
stick up for last year's oscars i know
it was much maligned the kind of
quarantined union station one to me it
felt like how the oscars began a group
of people at the ambassador hotel loving
each other's work i like watching the
oscars try new things to be honest
this year's best picture winner then
ladies who do we think is is going to do
it for so long we've been talking about
power of the dog being being the
favorite has things changed now the pga
awards have always kind of predicted
what the best picture winner is going to
be and for the past 22 years and so we
had koda win at the pga awards last week
and so it's definitely going to be at
least a very tight race between coda and
power of the dog what does excite me
though about this year's crop of best
picture nominees is how eclectic they
are i mean i've been sick to the teeth
of how it's usually some historical
drama
this year yes we have that but we've
also got a musical a sci-fi epic a small
family film a giant satire it's at least
trying to push the boundaries of what a
best picture is and i would think we
desperately need that more than anything
it's a great lineup this year well even
if power of the dog doesn't win best
picture we're thinking jane campion
absolutely
absolutely so this is only going to be
the third time in history that a woman
is going to win best director too so
it's absolutely going to jane campion
well she is a phenomenal filmmaker and i
actually managed to catch up with
benedict cumberbatch who told me about
what it was like working with her
it's really all about jane and the
amount of space she allowed for process
the investment she had in it
the allowance of time in prep but also
in production to be introduced as
phil to the crew rather than benediction
you'll meet better to the end he's
really nice this is phil
um
was just really
empowering and enabling i could just
i was it was full permission to be here
which was quite a journey to go on and
so to the films power of the dog is of
course a front runner and there are a
fair few bricks in the running
[Music]
what you're doing getting mixed up with
her jane campion's westin leads the
nominations with 12 including a best
actor nod for benedict cumberbatch 25
years since our first run together 1900
and nothing
it's a long time
british hopes also lie with kenneth
branagh's semi-autobiographical drama
belfast which earned him a director
nomination and dame judy dench a
surprise spot in the supporting actress
shortlist
and the time keeps ticking olivia
coleman and andrew garfield are also
among the british contingent he told sky
news he welcomes oscar recognition as it
shines a light on the work of playwright
jonathan larson
to play jonathan has been one of the
most meaningful
kind of experiences of my life so the
more i get to talk about him and the
more i get to talk about
what he was about ethically and the
songs that he sang and who he was
singing for that feels so yeah it's a
beautiful thing to be able to share his
story
[Music]
but there was no room for spider-man or
bond in the best picture lineup despite
the academy insisting on an expanded
list
it's interesting to see the changes that
they've made in the hope that by having
10 nominees that you'd get some more of
the big hitters in there and the kind of
films that a lot of the public would be
going to see and want to see nominated
at the oscars but very interesting that
no time to die didn't make it into best
picture and only had three nominations
that of course the film that kind of
saved cinema in some ways
the pressure is on the oscars to do
something to halt declining audience
figures with last year suffering more
than a 50 percent drop in viewers
and in a post-pandemic world just as
cinemas relied on films like june with
10 nods and west side story with seven
to bring back customers the academy now
looks to this spielberg magic to lure
audiences back to the oscars
one of our big british hopes this year
is the kenneth branagh's film belfast
could we see sir kenneth maybe getting
screenplay do we think best original
screenplay i'm saying is going to go to
him actually i managed to catch up with
him when belfast came out here's what he
told me about growing up in belfast it
was really to see whether you could find
the story of a family in a difficult
situation where humor and all the other
coping mechanisms we come up with to try
and deal with difficult times could
speak to other people and this lockdown
promoted that i think because the
introspection and the
feeling unsettled that we we've all
shared really drove me back to that time
gothic western the power of the dog is
the favorite to win best pitcher but we
all know academy voters love an underdog
so the question is can surprise indie
hit coda sweep in and take the knights
big prize
[Music]
it is a simple story but koda is one of
the most radical oscar contenders this
year authentically cast and
revolutionary in the insights it offers
into deaf culture
less than a decade ago in the original
french film that it's based on most of
the deaf characters were played by
hearing
actors foreign
in what feels like a landmark moment for
deaf people coder actor troy kotzer is
the first male deaf actor to be
nominated for an oscar marley
but it's been 35 years since marley
matlin's best actress oscar win for
children of a lesser god
within oscar history coda will be
remembered alongside the greats not only
for how deaf people are portrayed on
screen but for how its success
represents an acknowledgement within the
industry that authentic casting matters
but there's still a long way to go
star of a quiet place 2 million simmons
says it's wrong that only a handful of
deaf actors are working in film
i've never done anything without my
family before
regardless of whether koda wins best
picture the success of this boundary
shattering film already represents a win
in terms of who hollywood is now looking
to cast
[Music]
and you can get more oscars intel on our
sky news backstage podcast and don't
forget to watch the ceremony exclusively
on sky cinema from 11 on sunday night
and join me live on sky news on monday
from the vanity fair party with all the
winners
[Music]
[Applause]